[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to GameSpot
my name is Nick margarita
I am the B squad chillin here with Jake
Decker
what's up Jake how's it going it's going
well how are you I'm pretty good
I'm so nervous gotta brought up to the a
squad today yeah so if you noticed
Mike's not here he has a doctor's
appointment or something allows the
excuse I say but anyway Nick's gonna
gonna gonna be filling in for the
sheriff of raw shock so anyway let's uh
let's get right into it so are we doing
anything specific today uh well it is
called we're gonna try to get head shot
punches when we land however we aren't
gonna stick to that because there's no
way to win if you're well I mean I guess
you could win I mean twitch one like
twitch plays battlegrounds came in
second or something like that which is
kind of cool which is insane but all
right we're not gonna win by getting
head stuff punch so we land we're gonna
try to get some head shot punches then
after that we're gonna grab guns in and
get that chicken dinner imagine if we
got a chicken dinner without Mike today
that would be my crown jewel my my
crowning accomplishment here Billy cat
says I know bossy Mike today lol you can
hear this thing right good I can hear ya
yeah you don't wanna hear my audio yeah
alright I'm playing on the the gaming
laptop the GameSpot gaming laptop so
this can be a little new for me but I
feel pretty good
and then I'm playing on the stream when
we said been able to set up like being
able to switch between streams that's
okay no one needs to see my screen the
problem is is that it's hard to switch
while you're playing door 4 says bye bye
George
also we are in the comments on twitch
and YouTube yeah site if you want to say
this up you want to tell us if you
something
GUP shoe says no sheriff today alrighty
sheriff you got fired get the turn in
this badge gun
[Music]
the air tank you never gave
turn it back up and jump out of the
plane
alright hey let me know if that's good
where we going
put [ __ ] this is your this is your
stream I'm just living in it
all right will do put [ __ ] will start
writing the action we're gone for it boy
that's aim for yellow where I marked Oh
Oh what my piece he just did something
funny
oh no oh boy okay I'm coming up coming
up coming you're not gonna make it to
Ross LLP see problem his PC went to
black game didn't crash it just went to
black so he brought that window back up
yes on the other side of the villains
I'm coming
try to try to find a car and just get to
me this happened last time I hit F
instead of W and leapt out of the plane
too early oh really
yeah drove a car all the way to Mike hit
a rock and died uh I'm gonna go for a
car it's probably the best idea I'm
gonna land in one of these buildings I
think I've missed the the battles I
don't know if I'll be able to get any
headshot punches cuz I landed so late
actually there's a car here if I just
pick you up if you want that's up to you
I'm gonna see if I can get a weapon and
I think I have a Jeep - okay if you've
got a Jeep you come to me cuz me dry
yeah you only go through these houses
really quick you might as well if no
one's there Inc I can check if that's a
burnt-out
Jeep Wow gube wants to know if we're
gonna do any we do any first-person no
yeah no thanks I'll pass
how we doing how we doing on gear I
found a revolver but that's like a slap
in the face oh I found that a UMP so
release cooking with a little bit of gas
not quite all the gas oh I'm a
psychopath and I use um I used caps lock
as Oh to run as my sprint and it's not
set for that is it no I'll switch it a
little bit oayk a nice let's go this
door is open and ice that doors open - I
still don't have a gun I probably should
have grabbed that pistol damn a lot of
UMP says Jake is soft
wow wow dude we haven't even have
anything gotten any battles yet your car
up calling him soft
Jake and I had a very exciting weekend
beautiful music festivals so if we're a
little rusty maybe we're a little tired
no excuse no excuses though all right
okay I have a UMP and a new red dot and
an 8k but with only 60 rounds well I got
om sixteen right I'm gonna try to go get
that car and get to you now I think I
have enough to just where am I
I heard some gunshots oh there's a guy
oh dang yep I'm being shot I think I'm
hearing that through these other heads
thought you were near me
I'm knocked down already yep
I'm coming are you out totally no I'm
gonna bleed out what should we do she
just restart see if you can get to me
all right
how much time do I have not a lot of
time not a lot of time there's no way
you're not gonna get to me no way I will
just we'll run it back we'll run it back
because I got stuck yeah we had a we had
a black art ring that yeah before we
began I think that's a technical problem
uh what's up
Itaewon Quinjet mom coffee yeah okay
this will make sure this audio is good
all right I had a really stupid screen
name I think they're talking about daddy
dabs that guy is really stupid screen
name I don't know what you're doing
dabbing on these boys all afternoon oh
man
he was that cringey enough for you who
said that
dizzy deaf you think that's a cringe
cringe worthy name oh I'm gonna quickly
change that sprint
audio keeps cutting in and out for me
like I know they're getting it fine it's
just my yeah
yeah that's okay I'm only getting it in
the right ear
all right here we go just gonna switch a
little button here yeah there we go
yeah here we go I can hear both both
sides now
okay this is the real first game all
right it's raining we've got the element
of surprise
all right let's see sure all right
or should we just do gosh we just jump
out now go straight to Jack had getting
some fights go go now all right Jack huh
all right we're going what if anyone
will actually fall out yeah probably
yeah yeah what's good I know the new
update made it look better the rain
looks so good
you'd be covered in a shroud Jack it's
pretty small oh yeah oh yeah all right
whatever you do don't head punch me all
right I'm going for the one that's going
in the middle you two
yeah let's just both get this guy all
right there he is he's going in this
building ah crap we don't have a gun now
uh are you after him yeah where is he
he's looking for a gun does he jump it
out no oh God get in get in get in get
inside I'm upstairs oh my god I have no
gun I'm dead you're dead
I am i he's coming for you he's coming
for me you and Izzy UMP
I think he's upstairs the guy with UMP
yeah watch out
Oh God
alright here we go boys and girls
where's his buddy did he jump down
I think he might have jetted kills you
and ran he's got a UMP though I know
that because he blasted me Oh careful
careful all right
it annoys me that you pull the parachute
so soon I didn't pull it it pulled
automatically it was because I wasn't
going straight down so it was kind of
early
all right rough start I never pulled my
parachute
I always just I always let it go in it
naturally does
all right rough start for the B squad
I'm rough start I got some punches in
though got some punches gee Scoob you
started a bully I know he in twitch chat
he says if Nick was the one capping
footage for first person I'd be worried
I would be worried as well to be honest
first person is a nightmare
all right oh man no more rain damn no
more rain I did you goob just said at
least you didn't get pan did you get
pans in a previous episode I don't think
I did I think Mike did Mike did yeah
Mike got paint that's uh kind of brutal
I do remember that I've never actually
seen this tommy gun in neither have I so
I can't I think it's only in the drop
boxes it is so satisfying to shoot
though so what do you think how far out
are we from the new map uh two months at
least all right two months isn't too bad
me and a group of people have ganged up
on this guy with the fancy jacket and
we're just shooting him nice anyway
how's everybody doing in the chat I'm
gonna try to play and keep an eye looks
like Jay
in the crew bird chillin arise fuse that
annoys me so much that you don't jump
there talk so soon
I know I addressed that go and jump it
will pop right here ah nuts let's go
yeah yeah I don't know why it does that
I wish you'd like dive bomb and pull the
chute from last second our total to jump
[Music]
all right now Mikey's the sheriff or
this this here town right dizzy death
says I would like to see them doing more
crowded city map I think oh shoot I'm
going the wrong way
yeah where you going oh no I'm good
a more crowded city map I think the
desert map is supposed to be smaller I
feel like I heard that somewhere where
do you want to end up top or bottom
south bottom all right how many people
you got around us any tips on playing
solo hide hide yeah seriously I know a
lot of people say it's like cheap and
whatnot but personally I like to land in
somewhere a bit busier and see if I
survive and if I survive then I play
more defensively because it gets the
adrenaline going if you get a couple
kills yeah rather than just you land in
the middle of nowhere you don't see
anyone you'd gear up and die at least
like you have a chance to get some
combat you can ready yourself either car
I didn't see anyone else land here but
your car hard I don't hear a car where
are you I'm right over here I'm like to
your right I hear a car though he must
be right here yep Arius there's a guy
running I'm going after him or is he
getting in that car [ __ ] oh don't
die
watch out they're coming for you for me
yeah the cars coming towards you
no they jet it they're gone I don't I
don't want to revolver I their crappy
gun what graphics you have on it Nick
what graphics you have on this view is
it ultra I think it's just high I don't
think it's on ultra I could be wrong
though don't hold me to it alright I
have a pistol so at least I'm defending
oh god someone's coming in to your
building yeah all right I'm coming are
they shooting at you
yeah he's got an ache ham yikes he's
gonna yeah he hasn't they call him and
lettings in the other so human kill him
I shot him he's hurt I think he's gonna
try to heal [ __ ] Oh run run damn oh my
gosh how the hell did he have an AKM so
soon he just got lucky
alright like alright I hate the revolver
so much hate the room I usually just
don't pick it up
I know normally I don't either but I
heard gunshots than you were already
dead
Oh goob you must be having a ball in the
chapel with the way this is currently
going all right we got this I just
amazing FPS on every game besides this
game you have a 970 at home and I agree
I seem to have pretty good at FPS on
everything and then I play this and
especially here the FPS is really low
when I jump out of the plane the FPS is
really low yeah
sometimes in the cities it can be low
even this is a 1080i right or ten
seventy seventy okay
this person said he people are hit I
think he meant to put an S in front of
that Oh ahead
that's what this is it glory 13 rhythm
he said were the hit were the the big
hit he hit yeah
thanks thank you making my day neck says
goop's you riot
it's what I strive every day you know
where we haven't been in a while
Milton power ah damn going too far which
we go you go too right here you kick it
to Milton if you want but that's right
by the bridge
Thank You Milton you wanna do that yeah
alright let's do this and move we could
do a little quote a little code action
so we did before I'm telling you the
boat trick if you weren't here damn
jumping I was gonna tell my boy John
Luke we were gonna do the old boat trick
- no the old boat trick you guys ever do
the old boat trick it's where you get in
the boat and you avoid everyone the
whole gang
and then he only come to shore when you
have to it only works the panel at a
certain we came in second if we had had
the element of surprise we would have
got that guy all right I'm gonna land
near this warehouse how many other
people I see two other people looks like
yeah two people going from Milton maybe
a couple other people
oh and nearby establishments confirm the
guy below me too well there is yep
how about me I don't know I don't know
if with me following him either
oh shoot you're over on the right I went
to the left that's all right
just be careful all right I'm gonna run
through this warehouse I cannot wait for
them to Institute vaulting into this
game with me I think that might be the
most excited I will be for any patch
update good news padded jacket so let's
look at you
alright I'll come to you come to you oh
my what happened son with a shotgun I'm
coming I'm gonna avenge you and they're
just messing with me you think I didn't
Oh were they waiting for me they're
probably waiting for me no there's just
messing with me
ready oh man alright
jeez we are not doing well do we play
defensive do we play a little defense I
think we got to land in a city we at
least got to get some action in the
beginning
alright alright I agree wow this is
going well yeah I'll say maybe John Luke
should have played for me no I think
it's Mike I think Mike's not here so
that's what's going on here
all right I don't know John Luke and I
together we did we didn't do bad we did
solo though I think solo at least for me
is a little bit easier how would you do
solo though
oh you mean you were only playing oh
alright
oops just said you're making Mike look
good it's time it's time to play it's
time let's do this we're not taking
anymore
not taking anymore s hit
now we're gonna get smoked again I don't
think so I don't believe he's gonna pull
the plug on the stream it's the power of
positive energy is you're gonna pull the
big plug that shuts everything down that
would be sad hey don't do that please
bang-bang alright let's do this look at
that big ol human centipede find a boat
coward eat the chicken no coward we'll
do that after we land and kill some
people
I'm gonna try to land here I like I'm
almost never over here go it won't let
us jump yet you just gotta keep spamming
it until we can jump all right
so many people jumped it's fine with me
I'm going oh I'm just going straight
down except you pull the parachute or
later all right come to you oh god I got
a girl left above me uh no I see a guy
above me he looks like he's going for
the same building I'll take him no he's
going he's going across oh that's you
that's me all right I got a pistol at
least so I've gotten nothing he ran in
here doors open I'm not coming there I
don't have a gun I have a scar or no SKS
sorry oh you've an SKS is he in that
building with you no okay
I'm pretty sure he's in this building or
he's already left cuz the door is open
oh I heard someone pull a pin on
something careful careful
you said you've an SKS yeah other times
for scope nothing in here where is this
guy
I don't know I'm afraid I'm Kony home
coming in that coming in the door or
you're leaving
okay yeah I mean there's not a whole lot
here
Ernie these crates open nope
some of these crates have good stuff
Gill my time spore scope oh not yet
oh yeah you hold it just in case wait
until we're safe just in case something
bad happens all right
a little two backpack shotgun first time
I feel like I've really gotten a gun in
this today little to tell me damn where
is this guy
I have no idea
oh there is oh the yeah he's coming he's
going around the building oh god he's
gonna kill me get him Nick get him quick
before he finishes me around the corner
oh there's two of them like wow this is
not going well
oh yeah he chases come on come on daddy
jabs all right I'm gonna literally stay
on you like like what's the analogy like
white on rice I'm gonna just hang on the
back anytime so much shoot tumors shoot
them goob says 44 is our record is that
for today is our record that seems good
for today okay because I know Mike and I
have done much better than 44 though
let's say I get top 20 right now top 20
okay let's play strategically
how'd you get up there jumped on the
boxes oh then I fell all right here we
go
Group says today I think that's pretty
good for today considering how quickly
we died every game oh my god
no madam just disappointed in ourselves
where are we
raawk okay
sheriff train today
let's
go jumping
I'm gonna jump in three two one
Vaman I'm going straight down gonna try
to hit the ground as soon as possible
are you going towards Southend again
hopefully everyone's going through the
school
I kind of eased off going straight down
because I didn't think I'd make it get
good don't let Mike have all the glory
he's right anyone near us no I I mean
I've gotten more chicken dinners than
Mike though I've probably also played
twice as long as he has I don't see
anyone else land in here
good good story oh good a dirty tank top
I heared car hire car too
come on come right in here nobody drove
away Fry's buddy jumped out too early
dang
turn this thing off I'm dry there's
nothing in here dang yeah nothing in
this building my stylish coat here in a
crowbar but no weapon not even a pistol
oh my god someone just shot me I don't
have a gun I'm coming I don't know where
this oh I see him I see coming in it's
coming in I've got a shock and I'm gonna
I don't have any weapon I gotta get to a
building with a weapon Oh
[Music]
crossbow how we doin I don't see him I
just got a crossbow too huh oh my god
nothing worse Liz James says mike is
secretly playing and he's like hunting
us down on the stream it wouldn't
surprise me he's a big long con guy did
you check the the two-story buildings
over here yeah it was junk there was
nothing in it all right we need to cross
the street Oh God all right I need to
stay with you because I have nothing oh
my god I feel very exposed I'm closing
the door yeah closes book helmet Oh
pistol okay thank God need something
nothing
oh did you go in the roof yeah anything
level two backpack I have one of course
but one thing I do have still nothing
though nope nothing I hate this pistol
too long as a seven-shot clip yeah a
little bit stronger though a little bit
more power
alright where are we going I'm following
[Music]
all right
I'll go to the building just across the
street okay if I can fault over this
oh what a jump he's an Olympian it's so
satisfying getting over those insanely
frustrating when you don't though Oh
what we got here scarf yeah nice let go
m16 nice now we're cooking with gas as
Michael Hardy would say you don't say
that huh yeah he's he like likes to
bring back the old timey sayings that no
one says anymore you know yeah Oh what
else we got here a little first-aid kit
a little bandy bandages I got a trench
coat if you want it
singing look tank Macbeth nope we've got
my Laura Croft shirt I'm okay I'm gonna
bail on this crossbow really yep I'm
gonna go with the 10 gauge all right oh
you got shot too
no no I'm good I was looking at the
stream that's why all right Oh No
someone to you know it was not a good
vault so I'm running away to this
building yeah need some cover oh we got
a little red dot sight we got a little
pan action in here
not sure where to go oh do you see that
guy just jumped out of the know over
there uh would give me number 120 but I
think he across the street
no not across the street oh he just went
into bits building just one bit see him
okay he's getting in that building he's
gonna see that everything's already been
taken I just got another red dot if you
need it I would like one did you just
open the door no unless you're in my
building oh [ __ ]
careful man I wish this car had burst Oh
God
you think he's by himself
what the I just shot gundum point-blank
range
don't see me and I could vault he's
waiting for you is he really a little
does he know I'm looking at your screen
I know what he's doing
alright I'm gonna chill by this wall and
wait for him to come out well you're not
gonna save me if you wait oh yeah you're
right
you're right I thought you down you
completely I'm coming but I don't have
to save me anyway he knows I'm in here
right probably give me quick got him
where are you which room right here Oh
God Oh daddy down through dad ABS he
probably regrets not finishing me while
he had the chance
yeah he does he does regret daddy debt
he didn't even hit me let's go let's go
move oh sorry oh my god look at his body
what was his body I just moving I didn't
see
tilted up and moving I almost shot him
again oh it's even a gear he's got an
SKS oh you take that I'm gonna take this
shotgun stuff do you said you at a site
yes yes here I'm gonna put it in his
thing or on the ground I'm gonna take
that he'll me okay we should be careful
yeah are we we're in the edge of the
circle right yeah I just don't know
where his but he went down though right
you didn't
I died him not he does okay so his
buddies probably I hit him twice with
the shotgun I thought you were screwed
no way saw him through well I was screen
looking that's why okay no fit no faith
in the old daddy dabs cuz you know what
I did on that guy you know what I did on
I dabbed on him you're gonna do it I
just did Oh what if I what if I hit him
with you know I did I hit him with the
old double shot you'll for anyone in the
chat who thinks I'm being serious
I'm not joke I swear to God I don't dab
in my free time I dabble in death
alright I'm running up here soon seen
what we got these doors he'll shut damn
all these doors are shut
let go ooh a gas tank it's lit fam
Oh what we got here uh to level two
helmets over here y'all come grab it I
found in m16a4 you want it oh I've got
one oh you do yep
is that better than the scar I think
it's preference they take the same ammo
don't them no yeah yes they do they do
but this is burst and it's it is in
level wise it's a god weapon so I'll go
with it alright where were those little
two homies in there you ready oh yeah oh
shoot
am i far how's everybody doing uh dizzy
Jeff just goes recreational dabbing that
is correct that is that is how I would
describe my uh my dad preferences your
dad preferences how's everybody doing
the chat you guys bored yet good news is
this is our best round so far only 57
people left okay I am up in the
warehouse on the hill okay I'll come to
you no no real rush I don't think no
come on
okay this game there's always times aid
scope baby oh really
oh yeah throwing this on my watch me die
right now the theme of the day now we're
cooking with gas you go into these
little huts and I checked one of them
I'll check the other one oh shoot watch
a circle oh god yeah watch out watch out
bro how far do we have to go not too bad
not too bad we should probably move in
damn oh I just want that bad we can go
for wouldn't go on foot let's uh
you want sure go here twist rejector my
man keep on keepin it real stay away
from bikes this time and get that
chicken dinner did you see what happened
when Mike was like what's good in the
bike there's 12 people left no and we
got the bike I died and he didn't it's
messed up he's like I figured that would
be a good idea like no why would that
and it's a Mike move to like leave you
know he's like I can't turn around oh
car car car you want it oh right here uh
do we want it yeah let's just let's try
to go somewhere wild stall burr cut yeah
cuz we're did the I don't remember the
flight path was I think we came in from
the north around F yeah that would be
sick I don't think I've been a stall
bear in a while or we could go to this
little town here I don't know what that
is dangerously close to yes ma'am what
are you you were you gone
right into the ocean should we cross the
bridge
yeah you're gonna cross the island Billy
Katz is so far so good
hey Billy so since I have a sniper rifle
with an eight-time scope I think we
should be chilling outside like just to
the edge of the circle this whole game
yep I like that
Aria 0-2 on twitch once now have you
guys tried the new no man's sky update
I believe mr. Han Laurie is gonna be
working on some I I've been playing
around with it too I just started I was
gonna do digging a little bit more after
but it seems really interesting I kind
of wanted to stream it instead of this
today Bouldin had box so we go for it
ah no you know we going really well no
time let's wait by it
we should wait by it don't see if anyone
goes for it yeah we just ditch the car
there's already a buggy there there is
yeah get that anytime scope I'll check
it out scope city man so many level T
backpacks today like the buggy is still
there I assume he's not gonna run away
from it so let's see see what happens
here unless he's already dead feel like
we'd see the crate from here oh we're in
the circle too by the way
barely like we we Gucci open here mm-hm
maybe we should just go Nick and Jake
roadtrip it's like a WB show let's tell
me more should we just go somewhere else
you nothing no I don't think anyone's
there oh I get it cuz we're in a car huh
a little slow little slow Monday
mornings all right we go roll bounce if
you want
you're driving them yep getting real and
you're in the backseat what am I your
lyft driver yes
taxi would you like me to take you take
me to the locus local establishment all
right we're gonna drive by don't
beverages gonna look we're gonna give it
a look there's no I'm not gonna look
inside of it I'm gonna see if there's a
guy like land down by it
no now
hopefully he's not camping waiting for
us and luck or is he in here yeah should
we keep going this is pretty big area do
you like see doors open
let's just go solver Arya's your two
cents you guys prefer a first person or
third person in this game I definitely
prefer third person yeah first person I
feel like it's a real challenge and it
would itself in the fact that like your
view is so like tight ball got ran right
into it hurt me yeah it's not going
we're sitting ducks
let's go
[Music]
John the nerd says Jake I know him hi
John you know him
cool
it's a person that I know
say he's a friend I would say he's a
friend and you say Jesus
a little building action off right in
front of us thank ya it's like a million
of us girl might be tough there no we're
coming if they see us yeah coming in hot
making an entrance man every time I hear
you oh where is he
Oh
am i close one I can only kill 1 i 2
kills that round them Wow
I did nothing that round 2 kills for the
daddy dabs he couldn't kill the third
one sorry guys I tried they were fully
loaded cuz he had all level 3 year he a
level 3 helmet I think I think he had a
scar
I shouldn't have drove in there I lit up
the first guy though let him up alright
so what was that record 22 we were 38
and 22 on the team okay alright
woody oops you covering your face daddy
dabs I had two kills
give me a break that's that is 2 more
than I typically get to one that I got
I've I have not gotten a single kill
today I played defensively I just kind
of hide behind Mike and Jake and Michael
hi um if you guys know him from our game
tech squad I you just hide behind those
two and then let them you know do all my
dirty work for me group says the name
not the kills the name is great what hop
on board the name I have a friend who
has a name his Xbox gamer tag is Hobie
Juan jablow B oh that's pretty good that
is creativity at the finest what's your
what's your Xbox gamer tag Nick mine is
pancake face
it's pancake so if any gameplay clips
you see on the Xbox you see me pancake
face that's me and the reason
that I did that was because when I was
younger I was big Andy Milonakis fan and
his theme song used to go pancakes on my
face makes me extra happy and I'm like
oh it's my favorite line so it's dusk
out it is dusk
all right where we going brahs hawk we
go
don't you want to go south oh all right
those buildings gets do these buildings
flock wild it's laying on a roof careful
with true if you land on though because
some of them don't have a way to get
down without jumping all right I'm
jumpin jumpin oh yeah I was with you
when I did that that was one of the
dumbest things I've ever done probably
my entire gaming life I landed on top of
one of those buildings and there's no
way to get down I had to jump
idiot
I had a lot of fun that last one I was a
fun one this is a fun one
alright so that guy's those two guys
look you're going to the school so
that's the nice thing about here is it
like most people who land here typically
go to the school there are people that
land over here which one are you trying
to land on Center center yeah it looks
like someone landed on one of them okay
uh do you see him
oh yeah it looks like someone landed on
those two I seen em for sixteen so I'm
gonna put graphics on this building okay
good luck
should I try to kill them oh there's two
m416 here seriously yeah dang you
should've came over here there's nothing
over here oh my god someone's up here oh
damn I got killed some other guy on the
other building saw you yes a sitting
duck there's nothing I need to do
alright alright oh all wing man you he
would be chases punch him he wasn't on
my building he was on two buildings over
I mean he must have had a long range all
right shoot damn that sucked
there were two m4 16s in that roof there
still are up there when I'm focused on
surviving yeah damn not enough space I
need a backpack oh they're little two
backpacks up there - it was literally
m416 at level two backpacks alright here
we go
don't want to do that oh oh you can't
put that on it
got to get you a little suppressor for
that thing seriously I heard everybody
that's saying I should have punched him
how was I supposed to punch him he's on
another building the Jason mask yeah
friendly reminder well I'm thinking
about it and on the subject I don't
forget if you're on the youtubes to hit
the like button if you are enjoying our
stream I would totally understand if you
don't want to do though because we have
been sucking it would be really kind if
you did don't forget to subscribe
because every day every weekday we have
a nice little stream action going on
around 11:00 a.m. Pacific and so you
should tune in every day check out what
we're playing we play some new games we
play some games that are trending like
pub G we play a lot of stuff when I
first drops but yeah don't forget to
subscribe
it's game spot off your yarn YouTube and
I'll let you it'll notify you when we go
live and if you're on Twitch hit the
follow button and yeah we got a lot of
lot of cool stuff coming up
a lot of interesting things be careful
this was the roof he shot me on my dead
body and a little tube backpack should
be right behind you but watch out
because that dude was in the building
across loot daddy dabs it's so sad I
have to Mike mihari can't believe he
didn't even try to punch that dude I
hate all of you level level up gaming
though he gets it Pub G in a nutshell
land in a house find a ton of weapons
and ammo step out the door ready for
battle
shot in the face by a camper with
shotgun was it quite was it quite like
that but might as well have been like
he's on that building and I know you
can't you have to jump from that
building
no way to get down disability yes he was
on top of that hill on that one hmm he
probably already jumped in Mike my Hardy
he's giving you [ __ ]
yeah he's frustrating me we've a new
visitor hello I'm Ryder new fan of the
show are you guys playing agents of
mayhem tomorrow I am not sure what is on
sched for the stream tomorrow ETA if
you're watching and you're on let me
know if you know what the sketch looks
like tomorrow hello Bob Jones how are
you be careful cuz that guy's definitely
still around here possibly maybe no I'm
the tallest one now he gone
guys look at this sunset isn't it
beautiful oh so beautiful what should I
do
damn feeling your wife to move from the
circle I just say it seems like everyone
bailed
alright get a move on jakey Django let's
do this again sit as a car sometimes
like sometimes a bike spawns over here
oh hi there buddy light him up
oh he's strafing I hope that's the guy
that killed me is he running he's
running towards you
no he's not oh now he dropped down
probably shouldn't shot him yet
why Yolo it's true and this game
literally Yolo oh oh there he is
you're on single fire don't forget yeah
I know watch out watch out he's being
sketchy oh that was it Rick all right
all right
32 let's keep it going Noguchi no bueno
it's good it's because I was protect you
yeah when you teammate had dies it's
just kinda like that just gonna go for
it new record no that's not the new
record that's time get out of here yeah
18th out of 50 brah what's your record
GUP all right well that stunk that did
he killed me right away I hate that
oh yeah yes yeah it sounds like it's
good oh no I lost it
there we go no there yeah yeah lost it
again yeah that sounds good yeah let me
shoot I can tell everyone the chats
probably like what are they talking
about we're like yeah right there
perfect yep Gucci mr. Hardy today do we
know is it a dog confront I think he's
back now though he's a doctor's doctor's
appointment I can't wait to I have a
special photo to show Mike today well we
got out bro
didn't get a good enough look at it
though all right
I've yet to get a kill ever in this game
I've only been playing for hours yeah
that initial learning curve is kind of
tough but once you power plant power
plant I really do the power plant power
plant alright let's let's bring it back
to the people spam that F button power
plant kind of sucks people play God
I'll try to land in the cylinder in the
silo and the silo okay
all right I will too mike says what
photo it's an embarrassing photo it's an
embarrassing snapshot of Mike at the
Christmas party right
is this a mistake yeah they're gonna do
that I'm not gonna do that yeah I don't
think you can get out of it
can you I don't know oh yeah you can get
out of it okay but we need oh there's
someone below me who's landing here too
all right coming near you oh look at
this guy Oh God
headshot punching comment go ahead oh if
he's got a gun in here I'm screwed if
there's a gun what do you find just go
yeah he's got nothing
he's got a gun he's got a gun okay no I
hit him a couple times but I am NOT
gonna try to headshot punch anymore
we've had bad luck with people getting
like people just getting stuff right
away I don't understand I would have
lost my head if Nick had landed in the
reactor you can get out it's raised up a
little bit Mike is listening to every
trash word they're saying about him yes
he is I hope he is I hope he is I want
him to I want him to hear we got to have
one good game we had one decent game got
have one good game another half-hour
left so let's let's do this we had a
pretty good game before this guy's was
camping yeah I mean that was my fault I
I rolled up on that house too hot you
think they heard us yep
future embarrassing you get one kill I
got to bruh to one the day already let
go
not all of them level up gaming but some
of them are EMA Hardy used to be an
editor I guess he's not matter anymore
but he is uh on the video games video
editorial yeah alright pull it out we're
going south side of Roz Hawk okay
keep it actually you know what let's try
it let's try to East Side right here
wait is that you get at East alright
jump in now
the mansion has some good new usually
it takes a lot of people are going for
it for Rostock yeah what I have
we've died this many times
where's mate uh it's nowhere near where
we are well I mean it's kind of close by
all right you get a guy above you I do
it's tailing off the little guy below me
below II really yeah landing there's a
gun up here though oh he's got running
into that building that you're landing
by yeah I see em are you in the roof of
that building yeah a comforting traffic
gun over here oh no oh yes yes
careful I heard shots what I hear a lot
of shots I'm coming
I don't know how I got shot there I'm
hearing a lot of bullets someone's
honking yeah it's probably try to get
his boy are you inside the house yeah
someone shot at me jump dad you upstairs
yeah I'm running around upstairs it's so
difficult to like tell who's who oh
sorry there's nothing up there already
oh he ran out this story that's why no I
open that door Nicky's in his bathroom I
don't see him no Sam how did he get out
I have no idea where's the circle oh
we're gonna have to move oh god that was
me sorry Jesus so you already checked
this building this little one uh just
yeah just a little one going in this
two-story one I may not come back out
I need a backpack all right should do
Ranas empty son somebody you think
somebody was up here any I don't know oh
I was up there in that building
oh so when I landed on the roof of a
backpack Oh God
oh that was you I thought you were still
in the last building though you're
scared
[ __ ] alone oh wow keeping you on your
toes Nick you know whoo I am dead one
hit and I am down you got any band-aids
yeah yeah I'll drop my bandages on oh
[ __ ] there's a guy right there well I am
not in any condition to fight but are
your I come oh you just shot me do you
know me come to me
he's still behind that rock he's still -
I'm watching it he's moving he's moving
where'd he go trying to flank us I don't
know I think he went down the hill yeah
he did you see him I thought I saw him
damn we need to get out of here I need
health and a weapon yeah oh there he is
I see him soon
you look far enough away that we can
just bail oh dude we got to go yeah we
just run damn this is not this is no
bueno this is a boat over here is there
you know I said maybe no boat oh where
is he I don't know
[ __ ] this game day I had no help
wait yeah wait that computer up whoa Liz
she said welcome to the neck welcome to
the team Nick oh man Wow not my fault
[Music]
whoa scared me
you scared me when you shot me uh I'm
gonna just fill the chat in Jake and I
are now even you're now even though
that's true is we've both team killed
each other in the first few weeks we
started playing hi some guy came in the
building and he was in between he was in
between me and Jake and Jake downed him
and I turned around was like oh so live
and I just killed Jake but I'd just kill
him to like revived him I killed them
just dead oh I have a good feeling about
this
Nathan Shepard is saying military base
now guys it's possible plenty of loot
let's the multiplet military base do
what the people want since we can't win
we might as well at least do what they
want us to do I would also like to go
into the tunnels oh yeah tunnels are
one time people who go there typically
know what they're doing which I'm okay
with
yeah we know we're good
units of the GameSpot staff to do a
squad stream we really want to would
just simply be kind of tough but I think
definitely when the new map comes out
it's something we'll definitely be
thrown around
[Music]
military base is possible it looks like
but it looks like the the we can also
hit up the tunnels - you want to do the
tunnels I'm down for whatever tunnel it
shelters that down marks on the map so
we can go here or we can do military
base
now we'll do well just think everyone's
good on military bases on cuz there's a
direct path to it we're gonna be pretty
far from shelter - yeah alright we'll do
it we'll do it
shelter Mill Creek don't serve a service
I don't like it but I'll do it I don't
think I've ever leaned in right in the
middle of a military base
not everybody alright stay woke here we
go
you can't do first person in the play
more so many people are camping out all
right Wow you can't see down we've got
to stay close on this one this place is
way too big stay woke
stay with me say stay close state exam
since this one friendly five years ago
watch my ass
jakey's gonna blast me JT shotgun shells
jakey shotgun shell friendly fire beep
son really a lot of peeps yep I don't
even know the buildings to get loot from
here I'm just gonna go in this building
yeah never landed here before
in here YouTube got this is toast man
thank you
the the value of positive energy it's a
beautiful thing I have something I don't
know what it is oh I got a vector 5 an
SKS and great news fingerless gloves
everybody fingerless you know what they
say it's more tactile you know you can
let the people know get you can get some
better shots off now Wow I hate it in
here it's gross yeah
damn who who told us to come here I just
got in that scam lady Samson I think yo
this is lit there's a lot of gear in
here oh but look at that oh that's it to
work how far away are we I mean not too
far but we'll have to cross the bridge
almost certainly I have a sign up too -
which is kind of cool
silencers are tight yeah we go upstairs
here or not
yeah B I think you can only access it oh
wait no it just took me to the roof oh
oh Nick Nick I got it crossbow right up
here you want it oh all right careful
weird yeah like I'm going I'm going back
I'm terrified I'm gonna pee my pants
I already did I already peed my pants
I'm sitting in my own piss right now
guys peeing your pants is cool then I'm
really cool all right all the doors are
open in here where are you I'm going up
to the roof
you cray-cray dog see if there's
anything up here
oh wait helmet oh [ __ ] helmet if P and
my pants is cool consider me Mike my
Hardy
so this is the military base yeah we
gotta go though this is some funky some
funky stuff [ __ ] what what what guy
shot shot there's a guy in the building
right up here am i running toward you up
anyway he sees me
am i behind him he's at 75
okay my deal DeFranco you know try to
flank him cuz I'm behind these crates I
wish I had something with more range
mmm we're oh shoot is a fence here
yeah oh shoot I have to run around I'm
trapped in here the greatest enemy in
this game her fences low walls and low
walls oh there he is where he's running
through the middle I'm shooting them I
head up twice
oh they're both there hit him three
times we're by the cars during the
middle of the field at East directly
east oh [ __ ] I can actually flank them
Sam knocked one out I gotta come to you
because somebody else cheated me I mean
oh God do you down though no someone
else killed him but I got shot with a
car stay hung damn was a car
yeah the sniper
you musta killed the guy that I had I
killed one of them and then I turned the
corner and the guy was there damn I
thought we I think there were two guys
yeah they were they were being shot back
then I was being shot by you and then
someone on the other end and then I ran
in thinking I can flank him because I
thought it was just them they must have
saw you run in peace I was laying in the
I was laying prone and no one saw me
top-40 jake the snake' level of gaming's
is gonna pick us up some diapers thank
you what a wild stream it's been today
ha boy what a wild stream mine just
fresh a chamber says give me a shout-out
here try hitting the refresh then you
quit it in real on
yeah this whole thing is funky sorry
hold on you guys you need to turn it off
you said it well how do I reset this
[Music]
damn
we were running too smooth all right I
have to reset this hold on all right
it's all right a little bit of a
technical difficulty at the moment the
computer is hot yeah it is
it's red-hot don't we find it alas too
still you get a chicken dinner Oh Nathan
Shepard says yeah you got to get close
to Jake and Nick has to have your back
kind of try to fair there was just that
we're flying a team behind at a team
behind the team you were flanking that
got us yeah maybe you should hop in a
single just for now yeah having a single
okay I don't know I'm a bad fail
we go is this game coming to consoles it
is coming to Xbox one one I don't know
don't know but it should be interesting
with a controller that yeah they already
have roller support but it's not I
played for about a week with the
controller but I would like loot and
move around the map with the controller
in any firefight then I would fire any
fire fight I would use the mouse and
keyboard there's so much more precise
one of the funny things that we noticed
here just kind of among some of the
other video guys is that when you aim
down your sight so I'm sure that they're
probably working on getting the
controller more precise yet it you never
like really a announce I think I think
their plan is probably just to like test
it out and fill and hopefully refine it
by the time it comes to Xbox
all right I'm your wingman
all right
somebody was this dual hoochie
the trash
all right
we're going to go for the shelter you
are I'm jealous I know we can go to the
shelter again give a shelter if I don't
get some [ __ ]
that's something right yes
I'm also thinking of you that this round
you know you know what's gonna happen
you won't get fooled again where's the
entrance I don't remember
oh it's right there it is nice how many
uh how many chicken dinners do we have
in the chat right now just shout them
out alright so I see a guy that looks
like he's landing at the other end what
OH
[Laughter]
oh god I'm dead
get after him
no he's got a gun I'm running alright no
just hide hide behind the wall
did this person not even see me run in
behind I don't think they did
I don't think they noticed you Oh what
he mustn't noticed you know that was
someone else oh that was not that person
you never know he could be a
shapeshifter
alright I'm back so this thing is up and
running again okay I will invite you
yeah yo that was uh that was Devin
dinners solo one in duo I've gotten two
in duo one in solo and one in a squad I
don't think he noticed me ready yep oh
sorry
well he didn't notice me with someone
else alright I think it was someone who
came in on the other entrance you know
what we got to do this round go to the
go there again shelter dab on him go to
the shelter and dab in the shelter daddy
dads I would like to go to the shelter
though let's do it if the if we can do
it I like the shelter it's nice and cozy
well it was a quick and painless death
at least I guess I go cross watching
going on oh let him up get him you're
narrowing him got an arrow in his body
is it uh
is it a one-shot kill the crossbow it
has to be right yeah it is it'll knock
them down is that a DAB that's
oh really where are we coming from
really good in it we get at the shelter
jazz collection says hi how's it going
thanks for stopping by oh yeah
don't forget if you're on YouTube this
subscribe for more awesome streams like
this and while you're at it for every
like that you give us all down
I'll do it off camera though where no
one can see hi Rob how are you good to
see you this is a bad idea I think it's
my bad yeah but we're doing it straight
down
you see it I see it right there mine
hasn't loaded so I can see all the
entrances because those the only things
that have loaded so far which one are
you going to the one that I saw right
here no we're near each other yeah I
just want to make sure as you want to
right door anyone else landing around
here oh yeah someone else there right
there yeah there are other people let's
get inside quick oh I thought it was
like not in this location but other
people are going to be inside those
tunnels when we get down how much it
should not prioritize close over like
I'm a big close guy all right where we
going because I want to make sure that
we are together okay let's go this way
you should probably lead but you should
probably lead it's very bright down here
tonight
oh how you're shooting you've gone no
there's definitely something oh god oh
god oh god
alright I hit him get back get back get
back his friend has a shotgun but I hit
both of them a lot he's coming he's
coming
I know what are you gonna do s12 k damn
well we keep getting screwed over like
we land and there was one gun in that
place yeah yeah
do they have a gun of course they have a
gun Rob they always have a gun always
expect a gun you didn't have a gun there
no I didn't have a gun that's why I was
hiding there get I think if we both had
guns we would had it cuz the one guy
didn't have a gun and I lit him up and
he went down over to the side and then
the other guy came around the shotgun
just started lighting everybody up at
least we've ruined that one guys around
did you kill him
uh he was downed I mean he probably
revived them but he's got no beer he
only met some up you kill him speed
runny depths
you know goob Troy print says Peter guys
suck patrol today thanks Troy thanks for
stopping by
hey Troy thanks even though we're not
doing great thanks see you around bud
okay chaps stay away from tunnels yeah
lit sounds Gucci are you kidding me you
want to give up away from the tunnels
yeah all right I like the tunnels I
think if we I think if we're all
unpacked we should go there again I'll
give another shot
because that was like of course we're
not gonna win I didn't have a weapon and
it's a big long hallway we're off path I
think we're in the exact copy we just
went on yeah literally same
give me death says the next game will be
the one I can feel it
I hope you're right
so people want to know why I'm wearing
two
computer I play with and these let me
hear what's going on everywhere I
applied all night yeah
all right tell me one
three-two-one oh we got another Joker in
the comments cat gee yeah hit that light
you don't smash that like button alright
same entrance yeah
alright see it got your left oh you're
seeing dudes I see two guys to the left
alright they're going for the entrance
we're going for well I'm about to land
so go to the one to your left are you
just gonna go after those guys with you
oh my god they're four people over here
I'm about to land on top of this guy
though Oh God there is about to be a
brawl there's about to be a brawl it's
about to be a bare-knuckle bare-knuckle
brawl boys let's go this guy's running
away oh they're running in they gave up
oh god that guy's got a gun where's the
other entrance keep going that way keep
going then we keep going on I just mound
yes I think so
oh he's shooting me he's catching up to
me he's shooting me there's someone
following you great beam strafing
strafing oh god oh god Jake you're gonna
get me no you're good that person play
ran this person is trying no he's right
right behind me I know but he doesn't
have a gun yeah but I'm pretty much down
that guy shot me oh god dude what is he
doing he's chasing you now I'm behind
him oh now he's behind me this is wild
where is he I don't know
I got a I'm just running cuz I don't
have any health oh he's he's over there
he's got a gun now he's got a gun
where is he he is coming here to hit all
little three gear again alright oh my
god
I think Nathan was correct she shouldn't
have gone there don't go to the uh not a
single hit I shot him
you missed that I shot him with a
shotgun point-blank come on Danny go
down he shot him he shot him it's just
one of those days it's just the cards
are not falling in a place
got to get one good game here I'm not
stopping till we get a good game okay
good
we like haven't been in a in like a
position to succeed really except for
that one game that one game where I
rolled in too fast
hey chambers says when you go up okay
hey chambers I agree this is the game
although if we don't get the gear let's
not let's not try to land in the tunnels
this is why you could like it's time to
quit the game and your life oh ho
fraud boom roasted you got us this is
one of those games were like we could
play the whole day though no that's why
I've played so much yet where's that one
more counter at oh yeah ever gonna add
that every time we say alright one more
game we haven't said one more game yet
though to be fair we just said we're
gonna keep going into it where we going
military base
or here yeah we know that regular blue
yep I'm ready
a lot of people jump but I don't know
where they're going
we look pretty alone
yeah we're pretty safe seen any cars
around here now uh I don't see any cars
oh wait is that a tracker or track yeah
I saw tractor coming on oh no my great
enemy vaulting a little too helmet
alright UMP let's go keep that head on a
swivel lease fast oh nice a little -
helmet
all right baby we're cooking down we're
cooking here she is
we'll make a difference though because
some jackass with a shotgun he'll kill
me--he's camping oh I got a little
bandies little bandages you know what
they say man hears all bands and maker
dance also known as bandages we are
outside of the circle but we are pretty
close to it okay I say we stand foot the
whole game yeah damn there - um peas in
here you want one of these there can I
just take the ammo you just take me Emma
if you find any sights let me know
though I accidentally picked up two
sites to jump one did you check the
warehouse oh yes I did
so this tiny house the only one that
hasn't been looted yet oh yes all right
I'll check in Oh scar nice you should
probably take that because a level two
police vest I already have once - come
get it oh I do want that
I got a Michael Scarn here uh here's the
extended mag for an assault rifle I can
pick it up for your scar is that you oh
Jesus
we should call Dave do it in the coach
we should get taped to it in Oh
all right where are you I'm upstairs
Jason just chillin yo okay I'm gonna
drop that extended mag for you up here
nice and then I'm gonna pick up one of
these um peas I have no ammo for it
though but that's okay Oh another m16
I'm taking the ammo actually how much
ammo do you have for your scar Oh plenty
plenty I have 60 and I have like a hunch
you should take this why because I've I
guess I don't have that much just take
it you see you right because I have a
240 rounds for the UMP okay
all right we got it we should start
maybe not making moves but figuring out
a game plan here all right I'm falling
check this little even says the scars
rowdy I like it too I just need all
right I got to move through this field
we're just gonna go to those houses to
the at 30 northeast okay I'm thinking
we're gonna go 30 to those houses we're
gonna go up that hill and we're going to
see what's good over there we'll see
what's goofy whoa we'll be overlooking
poach inky once we're up there unless we
get shot down all right dope how's
everybody doing the comments how are you
hi we're hanging see how we do this one
I'm gonna be honest my morale is pretty
low Nick my morale is pretty low I'm
sorry I it's not your fault I want to
blame myself but tonight your fault
I can't we've got a couple kills there
which is two more than I typically get
whenever I play with you guys so i'm i'm
a proud panda bear dude
level of gaming says he's pretty okay
europe you're pretty okay
he means because you asked how you do
anything yeah okay that's all right is
there any mention of the new maps coming
out says black cat a nine one zero one
at the end of the year all right this
door is open no it's been knocked down
no it's open its open its [ __ ] there's
level two helmet though I have one you
don't see them
while they're morons why if because
there's a m416 in here yeah wow that
must mean they have really good gear oh
they just forgot to open this door I
hate this building
I hate these open spots these yellow
buildings anything in this building now
they definitely were here right because
I see that little shack up there the
doors open on that too we got to be
careful I think anyone's up here there's
no reason to stay in one of these shacks
now here's a quick draw mag for SMG oh
really I actually I'm gonna take that if
you need see SMG suppressors let me know
let me know all right you tell me where
to go
we're gonna keep moving up this hill I
uh I learned something really
interesting from Dave that I didn't know
the like gun holster they give you it
right off the bat I had no idea I
thought was just an aesthetic thing adds
like 10 carrying point capacity I mean
yet edits here carrying capacity
shout-out to Dave Jewett that was a dope
dope tip that I didn't know is that I
didn't like it I thought it'd look lame
yeah a lot of lot of lot of fields
seriously those doors open key see the
one I can see I'm hiding behind a tree
all right we're army let's yeah let's
chitchat about um chinki's about to get
bombed man I wish we'd gone towards the
water coulda done the boat thing
we should stay towards the edge of the
circle sorry I agree with Jabbar or
should we just crawl our way down to
that warehouse to chill him there I mean
it looks like no one's been in there the
only thing I'm worried about is are
those other people you know that we're
ahead of us cuz I probably they probably
went in there and are hanging out how
much time we have to leave plenty of
time
drew Green says hey read my comment I
read it there you go we read it great
comrade the heck out of it great
scroll down there
I'm not crawling I'm gonna run down
there crouch run Oh God we're gonna get
bombs we need to get down load this is
where we die but that team is I've never
died from bombing if this how no I'm
saying the team will be camping out in
that vault all right ready yeah open
that door what's up what's up what's up
no seems like no one's been here unless
they shut every door I'm going upstairs
good idea I'm gonna close the back door
not a lot of gear up here so that's what
I asked for for Christmas
boom scared
Oh what was that box bumps
it was a bomb from Mario yeah
any scopes any scope action nope no
scope yeah
no scopes all day today huh I found at
times a barely got to use it
alright we're almost that's you moving
around upstairs right yeah
uh yeah I'm okay I was like playing Oh
jakey is that you check this other
building you get old you are car car
are they come in here sounds like it
sounds like oh yeah they are they
they're coming in through the front door
I shot one of them a little bit where
are they they're coming in from the side
[ __ ] yeah careful you good yeah I shot
him a good amount okay
I'm scooting around to the other window
to see if they're trying to sneak in
that said I'm upstairs just a case you
need to get up here he left the Jeep
down there - oh my god what was it
chuckling yeah alright oh he downed you
Stephen Watson says play it slow yeah he
just finished me play it slow that's how
you end yeah we're trying to make a
little bit more interesting but I think
we should play as well
whoa well shoot alright Nick
yeah let's as much as I want action
let's let's let's do what they're doing
let's take it slow typically when we do
that we usually do pretty well all right
GUP says 18 is the record I bet you if
we play it stealthily we can beat that
record easily get ready boys and girls
cuz this is gonna beat one stealthy walk
in the park
we're decoy I saw come out of the Jeep
and I shot one of them the head two
times and then he must have a shotgun
right he came through the door yeah I
mean I I got to see I like stepped out
and he was there with a shotgun I
shouldn't have done that what if I
played with like the laptops had we'd be
screwed
all right says how much you want back
all right I'll put a little friendly
wager on this with you goob scoop of the
twitch chat wants to make a bet he wants
to bet that we can't be a teen team
ranked 18 team rank not count not out
okay just clearing that up making sure
ranked 29 not sure Steven I'll bet you
lunch next time I see you that we will
last past 18 right now
oops you ride in the twitch chat let's
go it's on Jake so we got a bunch at
stake for [ __ ]
let's do
I hate this oh my god I hate this track
what's left
oh god what where do we go do milta Oh
God through the North End of milta where
just do power plan no oh we got kicked
out anyway all right I'm going to milta
or we could see this in these houses
right up here oh no that's the don't go
there that's the that's what that's the
the lumberjack place or there's a cover
how about we go right here then so I'm
looking at I think it's that right there
for you which one oh that one okay
Oh a couple fuel with the power plant no
one in milta no one at milta that could
be good for us though playing it safe
I'm coming here I am alright here we go
there is physical real money on the line
here level two helmet in here I'm gonna
go raid this house first
that's k12 I'll take it best oh nothing
oh yeah hate to see your first weapon be
a crossbow alright we should move on to
milta after we're done here oh four
times ago
yay I have no gun
damn is
slim pickins in my building they're a
bunch of level 1 vests if you want them
but I should probably get one of those I
finally got pistol woo scar in here get
it
have you been in this red house the 331
yeah you have yeah there's the level to
helmet that you want if you didn't find
one car car car coming towards us
oh wait maybe sounds like it sounds like
it's somewhat close
yeah I saw riding by
I'm sixteen up here Nick okay come on
you get that are you gonna use that
times for scope not another side you all
right it's upstairs yeah
where are you up here I'm going to drop
for scope and I'm going to pick up 416
all right we head in the milta 30 rounds
I'll leave it on single alright yeah
yeah I mean we don't need to go we
shouldn't go directly into a buggy right
here and go where
[Music]
where was the that's you running near me
right hmm where was the plane he was
like down like this direction oh it did
yeah I mean what if we book and get to
the I was thinking all right great minds
think alike you're driving I'm [ __ ]
in the most terrible it's so terrifying
man
I haven't shoot them says Bob Jones and
we missed someone
what do you mean miss someone like was
there someone there that we didn't see
no chats like shoot don't shoot go with
it they may have been talking about who
drove by oh oh
boat boat gonna get in the boat there's
got to be a boat here yeah I see one
actually no a bit out
there's usually like 10 boats here
seriously
no boats
because it oh don't mess this up I gotta
have me some boats and and Bros boats
and froze boats approach where there's a
boat c1o I mean we're almost there guys
right there
all that hurt me that's [ __ ]
all right
hey seeing people here alive Nick oh my
favorite number everybody don't go on
the bridge nope we are definitely not
going on the bridge the bridge is scared
do you even know it's not this yeah this
is stump we're getting in position first
we're gonna get in a good position and
then we're gonna hunker down
I'd be quiet a definition of stuff right
you might be right
gotta have me my boats and robes this is
the game
I'm not saying chicken dinner but I
think will do and will do decently if we
got just water I don't want I just want
goop to have to buy you a chicken dinner
yeah yeah he's been very quiet in the
comments since you scared him I'm scared
I think I've spooked him Remy in the
comments this question mark question
mark
what's up got any questions feel free to
toss them up in the chat and I'll give
them the old JP here which I may or may
not have an answer don't forget
everybody hit that like button just
because you're fantastic nice people and
who won't have to oh man hit that
subscribe button so you're notified when
the GameSpot who goes live every day
every weekday 11 a.m. Pacific time
Nathan Shepard special shout-out to you
I feel like you can walk through the
whole day Nathan yeah and they can spend
thanks for your truth Nathan's been our
third team member yet you're a trooper
you can deal with us
slowly struggling
chuckling guys to the game I did play
guys to the game here what do we do here
should we get in one of these buildings
I guess I got hurt again how really yeah
we're gonna have to move soonish
probably though already been looted
maybe not make sure to close doors
behind you yes looted UMP all right I'll
go with you somebody I believe I can't
look at the chat for a hot second
somebody said that we got a chicken
dinner there free beers in Scandinavia
for us
Oh some freebies O's is what I like to
call them level 2 police feste already
have 100 scope e scope scope for time
nice and a red dot you need a red dot no
I mean what's your other gun like I have
a shotgun I probably won't be looking
down sights oh I don't have another guy
shotgun oh you should've got the UMP
then I grabbed the shotgun my two kills
today I've been shot level 2 back cool
why didn't have a backpack that whole
time
I don't know backpacking there just
realized three level ones in here
there are no backpacks answers were
there I didn't see there's more
buildings around here though they seem
to be empty right the buildings yeah
no no they seem to be like I'm saying
like no one's here
oh yeah yeah they see I mean there's a
hollow site here I just grabbed the oh
goody Jake guess what a revolver mmm
take that well there are a ton of
buildings here yeah freaks me out
um yeah okay I was like I'm moving gube
says still not dead I wonder if he
missed the whole thing about the bat no
he knows he knows Oh what do we got here
416
I'm not how much ammo do you have for
your m16 mod just thirty but you need a
backpack huh
yeah there's got to be a backpack ammo
though all right I just maxed my space
you go upstairs
No Oh what is this which one is the ID
I'd switch that for sure no backpack yep
for you no but I mean I'm good I'm good
I'm actually like fully loaded I only
have what's necessary some healing stuff
nothing up here some healing stuff would
be dope oh [ __ ] we should probably get
them out alright it's closing in dead
center hmm yeah I was gonna say take the
boat can't take the boat we'll have to
start moving we have two minutes 30
seconds
let's check one more house if we can see
we can get you a backpack I'm coming
here I am dick lor garita here here that
lace up up G
do you guys know what Jake's favorite
game is I'll give you three guesses in
the comments here we go you have to
guess what Jake Decker who's seated
right next where you have to guess what
his favorite game is it's a recent game
we'll give you a clue not an old game
2015 is it really 2015 I know what
you're gonna say wasn't like 2017 nope
now what you're thinking of oh really
alright this door is open tube says what
you're three you're wrong
oh that's cuz you know Kubas right you
got it you're wrong it's Gwen his
favorite game is plant I don't work on
my Gwent deck how are there no
mother-effing background on this gosh
darn town
all right last Billy I'm gonna check
right here let's see if we can get you a
backpack after that we out of here baby
we out here level two vest son of a
biscuit pistol quick-draw for my rifle
yo this is bonkers son
nothing all right coming to you
Yolo so far fudge it nothing all right
let's go I'm just gonna check a second
story or this roof nothing holy hit wait
let me check over here
backpack level one back all the way to
you and let's go on it no we gotta go
alright we'll just go then
dang it I see a car as an empty one
empty car you wanna get that backpack
then no all right did you check this
lookout tower uh no I like open the door
and then you said backpack and I turn
around and then I was like [ __ ] we gotta
go Jake's favorite game is clearly
sideways Tetris no that's my second
favorite
no it's quit it's not quite its quent
what is just the game Mass Effect
Andromeda don't bring that up
don't bring that up it still hurts
alright you grab the car I'm quickly
looking in this little garage thing
there's a buggy up here buggy should we
take the car buggy buggy are you sure
you got more protection in the car
alright you write car
a little
not yet I saw like two of them
invest it is shelf up drag to me all
right you in I say we should go right to
the edge right there or do you want to
go those big buildings I think we played
it smart by coming all the way around
yeah maybe stay down here yeah okay we
[ __ ] guys chill chillin I'm getting
nervous yeah lunch is on the line I'm a
big lunch guy you are a big lunch guy
there's no better thing in the world
than just a delicious deli sandwich
oh you don't get deli for lunch yes I'm
hungry now that I said that Jimmy John's
or oh no actually
Sammy's yeah Sammy's on second Wow look
at us just chatting about lunch where am
I going
I'm gonna quickly hide in this crate if
you need me guess what no backpack in
the crate are we in the circle we are
barely in the circle good let's chill
here
let's hide in this crate it's got on the
edge guys yeah so that's what we're
doing we're a couple of crate boys a
couple crate boys lunch it's 4:00 p.m.
Eastern well we are on the west coast so
it's currently 1 p.m. Pacific what one
car you don't hear car or gunshots oh
now I do oh god there he is there they
are
there's the lay down don't worry about
them people are shooting at him it seems
like we had to be careful they don't
come by us Oh do you see how far that
circle is dang the cars outside of it
careful dude cuz those guys I should you
want me to go I've got the painkillers
I'll go get the car are you sure yeah
all right
I'm scared I'm scared I should be laying
down I'm gonna lay right here all right
and watch you oh the car is not even
that I probably do Oh car car car car
car coming toward us coming towards you
watch out get down just let me pass you
where the where are they going I don't
know I don't give a [ __ ] though
if I ran you over
tripod so where we going all right we
got a skate the edge got a skate
oh shoot we'll go around pinky over here
yeah yeah we have to because that the
line goes this way
so that side near like yellow and blue
the side would move see the least amount
of people
and Australia it's already next Thursday
Shabazz is I think Subway's open and put
cheeky funny funny guy over here funny
guy we've got a real comedian in the
comment I'll watch the hop you keep
you got buildings right in front of you
not even gonna not even gonna worry
about don't worry I still have a
backpack and I never worried about that
while what a wild day
remember guys top 10 equals beer Oh
top 10 of 10 is beer oh I thought was
you got to win to get free beer in
Scandinavia top 10 easy come on
goob I think top 10 teams are tough 10
alive though top 10 alive right goob it
was just 8 the 18th team I got it
there's got to be under 18
I've already surpassed coups thank
Google I think you owe me lunch I mean
yeah we did 18 right do right 30 33 I
mean I guess like a lot of one person
from each team could have died though
there could be 30 teams let's not get
cocky and let's just win it let's just
win it all right should we hop out now
Nathan says our third party says coming
in hot guys you might want to chill
let's see that it's bail these car the
only thing I'm worried about is a field
let me let me bring the cons circle just
in case okay you can watch that I keep
stealing I'm just gonna
yeah see look at this uh-huh are you
being shot at no I just heard gunshots I
ran I think we should lose the car I see
a lot I see I hear can't see gunshot
damn it's it's that little settlement
over there our bet is to beat 18 yeah 18
teams 18 teams yeah you said 8000 do you
see that guy yeah I do
oh I forgot we had four he's running
oh nice again light him up whoa I'm self
to Jay oh shoot
what circle Oh God oh I'm inside of it
all right let's go where this guy was
going get on this little Hill he died
really quick no he took he took a lot of
hits from me
I hit him like five times should I go
free stuff no no are you sure
I'll stay with us a with you I mean let
me let me get up here to cover you first
yeah look at there's two people down
there get down get down get down get
down
all right you tell me I'll go for the
guy on the right you go for the guy we
want to shoot them yeah absolutely
okay
alright one guy slipped behind the tree
both of them did I lit him up though
they have to know no the grenade will go
this far oh it almost did I'm Charles
yeah I'm doing the same thing you are I
don't think we necessarily need to try
to kill these guys I don't think so
either
we did some damage go get it back now I
now like killing these guys are the
least of my priorities right now how far
is the circle [ __ ] the circle is kind of
far maybe we should just get up and run
[Music]
we messed him up pretty good I think I
downed one of them I didn't hit I think
I hit that guy Oh God
there they are right there well that's
get on the car the bike oh no those are
different cuz that guy's got a helmet
they just took off you see him cuz I'm
Charlie they were and they got in the
car drove away oh you scared me
we got to run the circle is coming for
us
I mean I have a first-aid kit so I think
I think we'll be okay we're just gonna
we're gonna get ding for sure yeah we'll
be fine
we're just gonna get oh I thought we
were a lot further out I think we're
okay right when we get in hit the deck
lot of shooting daddy jabs getting hurt
oh yeah you're in a good spot though
yard yeah look where the next circle is
gonna be okay good oh [ __ ] I gotta get
inside the surf I do too
oh oh dude I think I might die
it's all sudden my thing just oh okay
I'm gonna be able to crawl to you
oh are you down no no I laid down I'm
healing okay you kill me yeah it down me
I have a first-aid kit so oh my god heal
it's not letting me heal I'm gonna die
trying to heal you I bet I'm getting
shot at
oh why is this taking so long
okay get up.get mine's rock you see that
guide you see that guy's been shot right
now just let him get shot I got a heal
got him down down kill them holy
guacamole
jake is turned on the overdrive right
now alright I'm crawling to you I healed
up yeah I think I see another guy
crawling your way up there you do yep I
just saw him get out okay I'm trying to
get to you I'm not gonna shoot at him
there's no yeah there's no sense of
shooting I don't think anyone knows
where we are yet how are there 20 people
alive this is a small circle for 25
right yeah that guy is that guy just got
I'm just gonna let him fight I'm not
gonna shoot you
nothing fight and let them fight we just
need to watch the circle luckily we're
close we're close just skating the edge
all the circles moving it is
I mean slowly because of our angle it's
moving slowly because of our angle so
don't don't freak out too much get down
get down if you can crawl on in 16 baby
16 15 let him fight let them fight
let them fight God you see they're
everywhere they are yeah let them fight
I'm watching our back and our right you
watch the left side let's skip my trees
we got to get my tree I know that's what
I'm doing
we're gonna need to move though Wow down
we have some time though we've got time
we have we have the height we have the
height yeah let them fight alright I see
a bunch of guys off to the right they're
getting shot so I'm just gonna let him
fight let him fight if we win and I have
to kill someone shooting me oh [ __ ] I
don't know from where though and he oh
god he's got to be behind us or
something oh I don't know where he is I
don't know where he is
neither do I [ __ ] down down I have no
idea he's got a silencer I can tell I've
been running I've been walking around
the tree I'm gonna stay away from you
just we just probably a good idea
Oh God where is he he's gotta have a
silencer though alright well you still
owe me food got that lunch but at this
I'm still going to want that chicken did
Dinn damn
alright careful I don't know where he is
you have six five four three two one
alright got it right buddy right but
heed the silencer guys shooting you know
that's alright we got nine you you uh
six place for our team Wow
it's probably the best we're gonna do
today I'd say how much is NICs lunch
gonna be 30 to 40 beers - Avia - yet you
see chap you see what happens when you
put a little bit of money where your
mouth is a bit of money involved whether
its food or beers or whatever alright
are we I mean all do one more we haven't
done the one more game yet alright we've
been streaming for over two hours
how often do you guys how late do you
guys usually screen this usually we stop
after a little over an hour soon we've
been going for two hours let's do one
more
alright one more we're gonna do one more
his executive decision one more we're
gonna play it safe again now we're gonna
play it safe no more of this one more
this was the first time we've said one
more today hey it wasn't me I didn't do
the thing we're gonna do one more good
game wasn't me I didn't do it that's
okay I'll take blame for this he's like
the stream is doing really bad as is
yeah just cancel it cancel the stream
because you guys died hella faster
Goutham Eric how dare you Bob Nick needs
to do more gameplay dang maybe we
shouldn't well we're in this should we
just land in a hot area or should we
take it seriously you have a gameplay
team we'll be good
I think my counterparts can handle it
our third party Nathan concurs he says
one more all right they didn't do it
without Nathan like if he's saying if
he's saying when you do another one when
you don't know someone just said play it
safe play team
where's my team where's my team at
let's go - let's go down let's go down
to that ferry pier we'll just boat it
let's do here no that's right on them
let's do here all right
I think it's very far
grabbed me jumping
DJ says occurrence haha
Nik openly locking at work needs a smack
don't you dare go there slacking we tell
you I turn out 12 gameplay clips per
week let go get on my level they're not
good but they're 12
we need school in our life I don't need
school my life front door out of here
clear dang I was kind of hoping there be
at least one other team laying in here
pretty out of the way though I guess no
headshot punching today no headshot
punching I tried and I think our
thumbnail said headshot all right Nick
let's get you a backpack this game I
forgot about that
that really didn't come into play doh
like I had enough ammo and I had enough
things I needed it's true it's kind of
weird that like it didn't really matter
that much
oh-ho what do you think the first thing
I found was love you backe
well back Packer I got an m16 there are
no weapons inside here
get in there and show him who's boss
time ante they love you
these guys these commenters they love
you hey Kay let's go
no backpack yet for me it's your turn
it's your turn
maybe sleep Bob and goob no what's up
you got anything better do want you to
watch the stream yeah enjoy treat yo
self as as GameSpot's number-one fan he
is legally obligated to watch every
single dream from its start to finish so
that's why he wants us to end which I
totally yet if I was in that position
[Music]
he's like I just want to continue on
with my life like now one more game one
more game did you check the warehouse
already yeah same deal then I'm running
over to this house no backpack for me
though I want a little shotgun action in
my life if I found one this computer is
so hot that when I touch the keys it
burns my hand I swear to god this thing
is burning that means you're winning
oh-ho Jesus oh-ho you scared me all
right oh where do we go you know what
we're doing this game Nick what you know
we're doing this game what the circle Oh
Bo City let's move to Primorsky okay
I gotta have me my boats and boobs where
am I going we're going to yellow blue
blue yellow is where we just came from
I'll get rid of yellow Oh does that mean
oh wait you're yellow I'm young
gube says can't mess with the veterans
that's true she's saying hey I know that
say that we're not a veteran I I feel
like I'm getting there oh hey is getting
old oh hi I didn't technically I get
paid to watch this that's good
what's up in the YouTube chat are there
Nathan anyone else there hello youtubes
hello sight chat hello yeah you gotta
give him more time
that's funny ooh those burps you guys
should call this game one more game one
more game one more game
one more game there's a buggy do you
want it
yeah how would you get it where is it
right you know come pick you up I'm
driving all right old st. Nick
[Music]
alright now we're to the blue go to blue
yeah just follow this road commerce
always blue always blue always blue name
that show show Blue Mountain State
I don't know what is it
Silicon Valley the neighbors TV
cameraman says you guys Rock
Thanks
one more livestream one more live
alright we're gonna load up at primorsko
we're gonna hop in a boat then we're
gonna swim have to see yeah keep going
this way you're gonna go left
soonish after this checkpoint you're
gonna make a left
one more game mom our game this is where
ever you want to be oh yeah this is it
this is the city this is the city up go
more to the coast oh just well loot
around there and then hop in a boat I
think I already see one
actually it's beach 2 though that's not
good hold on stop stop stop stop it's
Phoebe it's look at that it's beached
that one's not let's just be careful if
you don't find anything in here I mean
someone's here cuz these things always
have [ __ ] one more game Mondays I love
it these doors seem to be shut though
I see a red crate out in the ocean yeah
someone just got it do you see that
thing driving around let's check some of
these buildings let's try to keep
together though I think what do you have
you said you have an aka right yeah with
that shotgun is that the only two shot
er no thanks I do want to shock them
though oh no no I can tell upstairs yeah
there should be we're getting health
packs though careful so I used to hide
in these bathrooms playing solo I like
hide the bathrooms like crazy I have no
shame no shame
all right moving to these yellow these
two yellow buildings appear okay man
that's weird this town still seems like
a ghost town but that boat was beached
well I mean massive it's true
but you think they'd be Oh Nick here you
go there's a weapon for you right here
crossbow
hey crossbows I just picked that up did
you accidentally pick it up Oh help pack
galore
nice I have a few already oh my god how
many were there too much gear you know I
don't have a secondary all right say you
running yeah checking the building next
door I mean I don't know what it was but
this update like added graffiti I love
it there's so much work your feet I love
fede that's what I call it stay on high
alert chaps have you got it you guys
should call it that too fede not
graffiti just a fede we got a guy works
upstairs hear ye big fede guy man these
houses are very empty like abnormally
and seriously especially considering
we're smack in the middle of the circle
pretty much like all these doors are
shut
jeez double girl shock and I'd rather
beat unarmed that's harsh
Wow don't barrel over here ooh band-aids
band-aids for the red dot sight oh
really
all right can I have it oh wait a bahala
just found home ha ha all right
level two best year coming coming coming
coming coming coming
all right where is the stairs miss oh hi
hola where was in the room where was
upstairs there she is there she is
we got someone says he just saw a guy
they did in the chat I didn't see
someone where'd you see him the neighbor
I'm watching I'm not seeing any that
door is open
yeah all right so we're starting overlap
anyone all right
this doors open careful cuz I'm watching
behind you damn there's a scar here so
they found found another gun they just
took the ammo alright where's the circle
going alright we're still in the circle
we are not as alone as I hoped
alright Nick I'm gonna check these
two-story ones right here you sure yeah
oh god there's a guy right in front of
watch out get inside get inside get
inside get inside get inside
did you see you know he's running away
alright I'm upstairs in this house we're
trying to see which direction was he
running away from us or towards I'm all
backwards since I got in here can you
wake up the computer
don't try to get to you it's maybe oh
good
the neighbor says it was by the house
there are many houses here I hope you
realize I'll have you know he was right
though I did see someone unless I'm
going crazy alright coming stay down
you're like I'm okay okay coming coming
come in fudge fudge stores open mmm I
feel like I should I take the UMP yeah
give me a secondary coming in so saw
dope saw dude some Bandys some Bandos a
couple couple of Bandos oh yes the
shotgun I wanted this is the shotgun
that I wanted what was that
maybe me reloading the shotgun okay all
right
[Music]
teleport says anyone else up for playing
pub gee uh yeah we're up we're done we
wrote for it but help a guy out if he
needs a teammate do we or a gal do we go
get the boat or what do we do I don't
think we should get the boat look where
the circle is it's it'll close in again
it'll just be closer all we can hope is
that it closes in on this logging town
here we flew in this way right I think
you think people are over here
probably not anymore well actually maybe
yeah I don't know I think we should wait
here though cause if it closes in on the
city we have an advantage I'm just
worried about that those other guys
I do a little inventory management what
do I need what do I don't need man we
both had four time scopes I was sick
I know
I just have a hollow now Nathan Shepards
agreed with me and hold position for now
hold tight hold tight all right let's go
get that crate I'm just kidding it's way
over there see it yeah you go for it
I'll cover you all right see you
oh you in crouch-jump out these windows
no way don't try it don't you try it I
got to break the window first I suppose
but
trap wolf says hello hi travel oh thanks
for stopping by
Oh Jason mask the waiter just stopped by
Nikki said our chicken dinner is on the
way really yep we're gonna get one yep
this is the game right here no it's
probably not a game what's better the
scar the m16 I mean I think the scar
probably is you just find a scar yeah
it's the scar that you dropped
whoo gunshots kind of close all right
wait what what oh they take different
ammo and what oh yeah they that takes
seven six to the scar it takes I'm an
idiot you you hear that I hear that you
best believe whoa that was really close
are you going upstairs yeah yeah I'm
coming upstairs to I'm scared I'm scared
she keep checking those windows just
keep checking the bathroom hiding there
Wow 29 left already Stephen says the a K
is faster killing than the scar it is a
little tougher to control though Shep
uses single or burst price singles right
I mean from here single but if someone
comes in you oh it's in the person
orders Otto Otto Otto yeah flip it to
Otto damn I see no one between east and
south I see no one from every direction
those shots were close though
yeah zone is hot says Nathan I agree if
it closes in on Primorsky that would be
so dope I wouldn't like that cuz it said
it's a game of chance whoever gets the
last building that's in the circle is
golden if you're not you're like running
towards the bill you're saying well
hopefully it closes down on our building
that might be asking for a bit too much
though no say a prayer you guys I'm a
mentally exhausted from this game
I'm ready to sammiches
I think I'm gonna do little roast beef
ham combo is that you walking around
yeah okay all right guys in chat let me
know what is your favorite coal coal I
see guys I see guys east directly east
so yep so you at the window over here
you we should be seeing them come we're
building yep I see him I see him
they're like running through here yep
yep there they go there they go there
they go all right they're going in the
building at exactly Northwest they both
went inside
you're hunkering down yep shutting the
doors behind each other - oh my - scope
bathrooms clear yeah they're in that
building
well it's badass look you're just on top
of me
[Music]
damos out of scope seriously
here's a here's that revolver if you
want it yeah actually
accidentally pick that up alright we're
about to see where the circle is gonna
go let's uh do come the bathroom
something going on in here what was that
what was that what that was me jumping
oh why are gunshots yeah that was
gunship those are gunshots alright do
you see the circle oh here here at
shooting alright let me see the circle
ah I know boat game today what are we
gonna do
where are these guys I don't know let
them let them fight I'm hearing a lot of
Grenada say you moving around nope
[Applause]
man I'm not sure should we should we
cross the street and go up that hill or
should we stay to the houses
don't forget boosters later says tey
yeah I don't have any I have one energy
drink I've to him actually you want one
no well alright well if you want to drop
it you're gonna drop one do it I don't
know how to drop just one control right
click and then same change that to one
okay should we move okay yes and I don't
think we should move yet no I don't
think we should move yet okay well I'm
just going downstairs what are we gonna
do we're gonna cross the street and go
on the hill are we gonna stick no I say
we I say we skate on this edge like like
there along the road I don't think we
should stay up there I think if we're
gonna do that we should go up on the
hill okay okay well I don't know because
I just don't want to skate along this
edge because if people are up on those
hills they're gonna ruin us you see my
face
you look alright alright we should move
though now across the street I don't
know what else to do okay oh my god
[ __ ] fence don't try to jump over
that fence
oho jump to first try I'm crossing the
string going on this hill okay is the
hill in the circle yes oh it is I call
we don't have
we don't have how you doing oh shoot I'm
good
we don't have scopes I wish be it's
alright the circle is closed to us be
careful crawling right here is like an
open patch of grass I'll actually run
down to those trees oh boats do you see
where it's closing in on there's no one
here there's nothing here
yeah that's why we oh dude do we go to
that little shack should we go there yes
let's go wait which one the one right in
front of you okay
someone's gonna throw a grenade in there
kill us both maybe one of us should just
go there okay and then I can watch
through these windows standing they
can't see me hopefully oh [ __ ] I don't
know where they're shooting me from get
get to the room the shack get to the
shack get to me get to me gets me
okay now we're sitting ducks I know you
know what though I would rather I would
rather be in here than out there trying
to figure out where they were we just
got to watch out for grenades being
thrown in here because that will ruin us
both
they had to be coming from the water
because they were shooting down towards
the door so I think they hit me yeah
they hit me so well they're gonna have
to move soon if they're by the water
well actually maybe not there's one of
those circular buildings there too I
know that would be ideal but I don't I
don't I there's someone in there there
has to be someone in there there's a lot
of gunfire like up the hill but I
haven't seen anyone eat a is like who's
ready for the double kill do you want me
I have health I might jet to the one by
the bridge that one the one right in
front of you this one yeah and then you
chill in here just we're not good place
alright ready get ready to shut the door
behind me yep okay no one shot at me oh
my god I'm shooting now someone shoot
again they have terrible aim it's a
sniper rifle too damn a lot of Windows
and this mother-effer didn't hit me guys
got a terrible shot they know where I am
now I hope the guy was shooting at me
now thinks that there's no one in here
it's only nine people left Nick are you
serious yeah what is happening right now
we're both still in circle oh my god
this is so lucky dude - I just chilled
by the door Oh guys I'm gonna guy by the
tree southeast don't I wouldn't worry
too much about it I'm protecting my door
another guy all right I got a guy coming
down towards you hold on I'll tell you
where he is alright he's coming towards
you I see him you see him okay he's
definitely going for the door wait no
yeah he's going he's going to get ready
shoot him get ready
get him
nope I died freakier okay
well play a cool Nick play it cool all
right so blast some of the shotgun that
guys doing the same thing yeah I hope
the circle wraps on you or not you lit
him up but he had hugh hadron a level
three
no i don't he had level three armor oh
he's leaving yeah Sam Lehman good okay I
see these all their fighting perfect I'm
still in the [ __ ] circle you play no
don't let me play
is it that team oh [ __ ] it's a team oh
no it's not no it's not they're still
fighting each other they're still
fighting each other are they a team I
don't know I can't tell I don't know
either
I don't think oh they're not a team
they're not a team because he's throwing
grenades and stuff they are team I think
so yeah look at there they're right next
to each other oh they are alright well
hopefully even though he's like they
just threw a grenade in there oh you did
good Nick yeah there really wasn't soon
as I came out the door they were gonna
blast me so whoa one more now I'm
sticking I really thought if that had
been if they weren't on the same team I
think you would have had a very good
yeah or if I had managed to kill that
guy damn ladies and gentlemen I'm just
gonna say I apologize for two hours of
play I made up for it though I think we
made up for it I had a really good time
I think everyone who stuck around had a
good time hopefully don't forget to hit
the like button and the subscribe button
so you're notified and we go live 11
a.m. weekdays Pacific yeah anything else
make sure to check out the new episode
of reboot it's really good it's about
help light if you're interested in that
game definitely go check it out
otherwise we'll be streaming again
tomorrow at 11 when they say sonic mania
tomorrow I think it's sonic mania which
is apparently really good so if it's
different take
anyway thank you guys for joining us
you're the best we love all of you that
stuck around for all Tunip Wow almost
three hours and we I'm using the wrong
mouse
you